mr joey diaz everybody let him hear it
[Applause]
thank you very much for coming tonight i
know a lot of guys had a lot of [__]
going on
yeah the republican convention and
whatever the [__] is on but the hell
with that fake [__] uh
i'm happy you guys came out tonight
there's testicle testaments and i've
been doing it for a couple months right
and what testicle testament was was the
answer to the vagina monologues i had
this idea
i did about 15 years ago i had this idea
testicle testament
and what it basically was was a bunch of
guys getting together and talking about
what
what made them a man not like when you
[__] a neighbor
or not that stupid [__] or you know you
watch your grandmother give a [__]
none of that [__] when you became a man
like something happens in your head
something triggered you you know
so testicle testaments i've been doing
it for a while and i gotta be honest
with you guys i've been coming up here
and telling stories or whatever
they were great stories and they're
interesting but
tonight is the true testicle testament
so i'm happy you came out tonight
and tonight is [__] murky waters
again so if you know
if you're in the mood to laugh and
you're against violence leave now
go go watch a disney movie or something
because we're getting down tonight you
understand me
it's really weird how uh when you're a
kid you [__] up you know
and when we [__] up we hurt people and
we usually hurt a lot of people that we
love not on [__] purpose
we just do things you know they tell us
not to do something we do it
and it really hurts them you know and we
forget it's a long life
and then comes a day we have to make
good you have to [__] we got a receipt
you have to make good
and it's hey listen we've all [__]
people you know some we wanted to and
some by mistake
you know you do sometimes you say
something or an action and people take
it the wrong way
and uh it's really hard to get that
trust back
or to get their love back you know and
in 2006 i had an experience where
uh i hate watching myself guys i hate my
voice i hate everything about me all
right so let's get this out of the way i
don't sit at home and watch tapes i
people give me tapes i do movies and i
just throw them away i hate going to
premieres
all that [__] cause i can't stand
watching myself but i had to make a
sacrifice because i had hurt somebody
early
on and i wanted to prove to him and it
wasn't with the movie
i just wanted to show him that i had
done something
so i went over there and i showed him
the longest yard in 2006 i came on dvd
and he didn't speak no english you know
he speaks only spanish
a little bit of broken english and i
kept looking at his face
you know and as i was kept looking at
his face i kept seeing that
the face that he had when i first had
met him
when i was a little boy and the guy i'm
talking about is my stepfather
his name is juan my dad died when i was
three
and you know i'm a crazy little cuban
[__] i was a little sp crazy you
know
my mom was rich and you know white shirt
with white shoes and jewelry on you know
when you're [__] four in new york and
i was born in cuba and my mother was
worried you know when she put
her friends around me like tough guys
from the bar she owned she owned the bar
and you know some of them would take me
to movies or tell me about women i was
like four
like one guy showed me a [__] gun one
time and he's like this is what you
shoot people with
i'm like what the [__] you know what i'm
saying i thought it was like a water gun
you know
but you know i had this around me but
you still need a man in your life
my mother knew that and i yearned for a
[__] father like we all do you know
we all yearn for something
and uh my mother come home one day when
i was like
five and she's like hey man look at
these pictures a friend of mine drew for
you
and they were beautiful mickey mouse and
donald duck and you know when you're
[__] five you're like wow
and i was like a nerd i like to draw so
this guy was like my idol and he's like
she's like do you want to meet this guy
and i'm like [__] yeah i want to meet
him
and she goes okay we're going to take a
ride you know meet him but it's a long
ride you know and
i'm like all right [__] it let's go meet
this [__] you know
i want to learn how to draw so she goes
next week we'll take a ride and go see
him
it's a long [__] drive you know i go
where does he live she goes oh in new
york we got to take a drive and all this
all right so the morning comes i gotta
get up at six you know when you're
[__] five
and you know you don't know what the
[__] going on they feed you and uh my
mother's friend
uh business partner drove me and you
know they like go to sleep in the car
you know
we'll wake you up when we get there i
remember waking up and just seeing this
dark [__] building and it was gray
and i was in a gray city
and i was at sing-sing correctional
facility right
this is like a big-time [__] prison
in new york
and my mom gets me out of the car i'm
like what the [__] is this [__] you know
i couldn't
i didn't know what correction man i
didn't know [__] you know but i know
what [__] bars you know like
so you gotta get in and i'm like where
the [__] are you taking me mom you know
it's like i'm taking you to meet this
guy he's a [__] artist i'm like
[__] in jail you taking me
i mean fool or a [__] [__] jail
and she's like you don't love him the
guy is great don't worry about it so
they search you the whole [__] thing
and
you go into this room and it was like
this way like chairs all around
and i remember the sign i said no
drinking no smoking no kissing and no
hugging
and my mother would always go look at
the sign no [__] no sucking no you
know like
it's a goofer mayor so and my mother was
crazy you know so we sit down and the
guy comes out he's dressed in his grays
and
i'm like this [__] guy's a prisoner
you know
and she's like he's my from cuba we knew
each other when we were kids and he
loves to draw and hey he [__] up
whatever so
we're talking he picks me up and he puts
me over and i'm like i like this guy
i mean i really liked him you know i got
to talking to him he would teach me how
to draw right there so i'm like mom we
got to go up there every [__] weekend
you know
it's like a five hour drive from
manhattan my mom's like no i'm only
gonna go up there once every like three
weeks to see this guy
so i kept going on i kept going up there
to meet him after like six months one
day goes hey
i'm coming home what do you want to do
when i come home i'm like dog i want to
join karate
there's a karate school on 90th street
in manhattan right on the west end i
want to join it
because as soon as i get out of prison
i'll [__] take you to the school and
sign you up
i couldn't [__] wait you know like
for months i would write letters with
him he'd write me back i'd draw like a
picture and he'd draw a picture back i
couldn't [__] write you know
and finally [__] july 20th 1969 most
people were waiting for the [__] moon
to the guy to land on the moon
i was waiting for my [__] dad to come
home you're following me i'm going to
karate today [__]
[Laughter]
i was going to karate i don't give a
[__] about nothing else what time is
this [__] coming home